as monsoon season continues we're seeing
flood channels all across the valley
filled with raging water this can really
be dangerous and even deadly for the
homeless living there that's why a local
non-profit is working hard to get them
back on track jamie j ford has more on
their mission tonight
that's right there are more than 600
miles of underground tunnels like this
across clark county that are not safe
living conditions for the homeless just
last week at least two people died in a
flood channel after the heavy rains fell
across the city but shine a light a
local non-profit that goes into the
tunnels and rescues the homeless
population says their mission is to help
outreach director robert banhart tells
me he tries to help the displaced
because he was once living in the same
conditions i was attacked by three
people three people tried to kill me and
they did they left me for dead i woke up
three days later in the hospital bed and
when i was in that hospital china light
came into my life all these people had
been looking for me and all the people
i'd known in recovery my family had been
looking for me and that's he offered me
a way out china light was founded nine
years ago by author matt o'brien and
provides referrals to community partners
that help accommodate instant placement
with access to treatment and housing to
the people experiencing homelessness in
the greater las vegas area from las
vegas jeremy j ford live local now